ah the goo lagoon so peaceful so sorry
observe the fish children as they frolic
and play and yet underneath its murky
depths a mysterious whose bubbles forth
be it good or be it ill what is the
secret hiding in the depths of the goo
lagoon only time and this episode will
tell
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film theory
where I'm ready I'm ready I'm ready to
get to the bottom of every unsolved
mystery every unanswered question every
age-old riddle from nostalgic
Nickelodeon shows and today we're
covering these things now let me give
you some backstory first cuz this isn't
as random as it might first seem is he
recently I finished filming a series for
Nickelodeon that was basically film
theory but for classic Nicktoons it was
like a dream come true
getting to work with a channel that
literally was my childhood we did
episodes at rocket powers crazy
skateboarding moves hey Arnold's pigeon
man Avatar The Last Airbender spline sky
bison oh really cool stuff we even did
two episodes dedicated to everyone's
favorite absorbent yellow porous
rectangle spongebob one topic we
analyzed was zigu Lagoon which if you're
not familiar is literally a pool of
water under the water that all the
characters treat us at local Beach and
shockingly there is a real-life answer
to that one pools of water under water
are totally a real-life thing I'm not
gonna spoil how it works you're gonna
just have to watch that episode when it
finally comes out but one thing that we
didn't cover in that video that I
thought would make a fascinating episode
over here or the mysterious purple
sludge blobs that come from under the
surface of the lagoon
you see SpongeBob SquarePants episode
185 titled it came from goo lagoon
revolved around the discovery of
mysterious goo bubbles that floated into
bikini bottom by way of this underwater
beach area the bubbles provide hours of
fun for SpongeBob and Patrick who
discovered that they were bouncy and
purple and according to Patrick news
group but for Sandy Cheeks bikini
bottom's resident scientific squirrel
the bubbles were something to be wary of
a potential danger that threatened the
very existence of Bikini Bottom after a
lot of floating around and exploring the
many joys at the bubbles - episode ends
with a giant goo bubble bursting over
the town unlike Sandy's prediction it's
not catastrophic but everyone does get
themselves a little messy mr. Krabs
cashes in on the whole mess and all's
well that ends well for our little
underwater pals but it's weird right
what are these things the entire time
you're waiting for an explanation and
that explanation never come
I mean why are they coming from the goo
lagoon and why is sandy so afraid of um
it all could just be a bunch of
throwaway plot threads to make that
sewed more exciting I don't think so
it feels like there was more thought put
into this thing than the episode let's
on one thing we've talked about a lot in
past SpongeBob theories is the fact that
series creator Stephen Hillenburg was a
marine biologist and so far as
fantastical as a lot of this show seems
there is a decent amount of it that's
rooted and cold hard marine biologist
fact like I said the goo lagoon itself
has a scientific explanation so why not
the gue bubbles that come from the goo
lagoon so I decided to look a little bit
closer as to what was really going on
here and oh man the conclusion of
today's episode is gonna blow your mind
I mean we're not afraid to get dark here
on film theory and spongebob sometimes
deals with some very serious topics like
ocean pollution but this one is pretty
awful sandy had every right to worry so
what's the dark secret lurking at the
bottom of the lagoon let's just dive
into it using the episode guide us let's
make a list of everything we know about
these bubbles first and most obviously
these balls are made of some sort of
purple goo or sludge you can see how
thick and viscous they are just from
watching the episode
so we already know that we're dealing
with an unusual color of goo that exists
under the ocean but we also know that
they're able to float and bounce not
only do we see SpongeBob and Patrick
floating above the lagoon while sitting
on the bubbles we also see them bouncing
on the surface of them the bubbles are
also sticky it sticks like glue once a
bubble latches onto you they're pretty
tough to shake off like in this scene
with Patrick speaking of Patrick he also
tells us they're stenchy Patrick
complains that the smell of the bubbles
makes his nose tingle the smoke goes and
you know it's got a smell bad because
this is coming from a creature who
doesn't even have a nose to smell it in
the first place and if Sandy's to be
believed the goo bubbles may also be
dangerous sandy for whatever reason is
utterly convinced that the bubbles pose
a grave danger to everyone in Bikini
Bottom we never see any evidence of this
considering that when the big one bursts
it only leaves harmless goo behind but
Sandy's concerns are definitely worth
making note of so that's a pretty decent
chunk of information all crammed into a
23 minute episode now put a pin in it or
actually don't cuz you'll wind up
popping our little goo bubble hold onto
that list because it's time to start
putting some potential explanations to
the test
fairy number one but who's shown there
are plenty of long-held theories that
spongebob is actually a show all about
the ways the ocean is being polluted and
it's pretty clear that there's some
truth in a lot of these theories there
are countless examples of pollution
showing up on the show if you kept
watching that diving clip from a minute
or so ago you'll see spongebob blocked
from reaching the water's surface
because of a layer of human pollution
that took a turn for the worse in one
episode mr. Krabs looks forward to
making money off the endless summer that
global warming will cause by opening
himself a pool one popular fan theory
even surmises that the entire show is an
allegory for global warming with
spongebob representing human impact as a
kitchen sponge
Patrick representing Western
civilization because he's lazy and lives
under a rock their words not mine and
greedy mr. Krabs represents big
capitalist corporations look I'm not
saying I believe that theory just that
it exists and that there are people out
there who do believe it we are equal
opportunity theorists here
folks I've come up with some pretty
outlandish ones myself though come to
think of it it might be fun to do a
theory review at some point similar to
meme review anyway Stephen Hillenburg in
interviews would mention that pollution
was a personal concern of his one of my
favorite quotes from Stephen actually
comes from an interview on that exact
topic my biggest nightmare is that I'm
gonna be at the beach one day and one of
these Sponge Bob dolls is gonna wash up
on the shore like garbage so could the
goo of goo lagoon be pollution of some
form like oil from an oil spill or
something maybe if you look at this
YouTube video featuring scenes from it
came from goo lagoon you'll see that its
description reads welcome to goo lagoon
a relaxing retreat for the residents of
Bikini Bottom despite the strange
ongoings spongebob and patrick have fun
on the polluted bubbles now I wouldn't
put too much stock into the information
contained inside the description of a
video unless of course we're talking
about the links in the top line of the
description of any of our videos because
you know that those are always gonna be
important be they sponsorship
subscription or merch link but in this
case the video here was posted by
Nickelodeon's official UK channel this
is an official outlet people plus
pollution spills tend to float because
the oil that tends to leak out is less
dense than the salty ocean water that it
floats on so you got the flotation and
you got Nickelodeon UK supporting this
theory but that's really where the
evidence for the pollution Theory starts
to run dry pollution spills whether it's
liquid asphalt in the Ohio River slurry
oil in the Gulf of Mexico or diesel fuel
up in Alaska tend to be brown or black
definitely not a bright purple which in
my mind is going to be one of the most
important features of the goo bubbles
that we have to account for in our
Theory Plus Patrick putting the goo
bubble in his mouth and being unaffected
by it doesn't exactly line up with
pollution or any form of toxic waste
though it may have been the obvious
first choice I have a feeling we can
come up with a better theory than this
one yeah number two
now when I say algae you're probably
thinking of that weird green moss that
grows on top of the water that you've
always wanted to touch as a kid but you
never did because we were always a bit
worried that it would poison you was I
the only one with that yes No leave a
comment down below let me know if I was
just the weird kid who was worried about
this either poisoning me or drowning me
well I mean obviously I was the weird
kid but I mean in this one select
instance anyone else relate to this just
me let me know if I was alone anyway
we're not talking about that kind of
algae algae comes in all kinds of shapes
and colors and species and one of them
the valonia ventric oh so looks a lot
like the goo bubbles and spongebob also
known as bubble algae or sailor's
eyeballs this single-celled organism is
found throughout the world in tropical
and subtropical ocean regions you heard
that right this thing is a single cell
but not only does it have bubble in its
name it behaves a whole heck of a lot
like the goo bubbles that we see in the
show able to float and bounce along
different surfaces on the floor of the
ocean as well as appearing to float
through the water bubble algae is also
known for rapidly spreading if one
bubble pops up others are sure to follow
quickly thereafter
it's something of a notorious scourge
amongst aquarium enthusiasts who know
that if they find one of their tanks
there's gonna be a lot more to come the
good bubbles behave similarly early in
the episode we see just one but mere
hours later the bubbles have become an
epidemic prompting news reports in
general town panic so what about that
vibrant purple color though Vilonia
ventric OSA is usually some shade of
green the color can actually varies
widely a silver teal or blackish
ultimately determined by the quantity of
chloroplasts inside that one cell can it
be purple no not really and well that's
already a stretch the point of evidence
that really kills this theory is the GU
penis this algae is hard it looks like a
smooth pearl or ball it's not easy and
gloopy like the sludge balls that are
coming out of the goo Lagoon so again
we're back at square one
or should I say SquarePants one
[Music]
but hold on all you sad Squidward's out
there I've got an answer that matches
pretty much everything that we see going
on in this episode the secret gu
underneath goo lagoon is none other than
dead rotting jellyfish theory number
three dead jellies my final theory for
the goo bubbles is that they're not
bubbles at all but instead creatures
that naturally look a lot like bubbles
instead jellyfish now jellyfish are a
huge part of Spongebob Squarepants the
show with Bob and the gang constantly
going out jellyfishing and looking to
nab jellyfish as pets heck they've even
thrown parties in SpongeBob's house and
while most in the show are a translucent
pink throughout the series they've also
been shown to be purple like the king
jellyfish and even blue we also know
that they produce jelly leaving behind a
goo that looks very similar to what we
see coming out of the goo lagoon but I'm
not here telling you that these bubbles
are live jellyfish or the jelly that
they spit out I am here today telling
you that SpongeBob and Patrick in this
episode are swimming around with and
covered in dead rotting corpses of
jellyfish did this mysterious purple
goop has been washing up on beach shores
of Norway and it looks almost identical
to the gloppy drippy goo bubbles that we
see in this episode of Spongebob even
death jellyfish corpses darkening color
as decomposition takes place explaining
why the real-life goop on Norway's
beaches is such a deep rich shade of
purple and why the goo bubbles in the
goo lagoon would be darker than the live
jellyfish that we've seen previously on
the show the bouncing and the floating
of the goo bubbles well that too is
easily explained away by the nature of
the lagoon I wanted you to have to go
over to that show I did with Nickelodeon
and watch their video to prove to
Nickelodeon that I'm popular and worth
working with again oh darn it but it's
taking them so damn long true story we
filmed this thing back in July and the
level of editing that that series
requires has got to be less than what we
do every week here on film theory anyway
fine I'll reveal the solution from that
episode but you got to promise me at
some point down the line when I point
you in another episode of film theory to
go over and watch that show and comment
there how much you love matpat and how
eager you are to see him on Nickelodeon
I was really planning on them having
uploaded the series by this point so I'm
just gonna go for it okay fine in that
episode I revealed that the goo Lagoon
itself is most likely an underwater
brine lake an area of super salty water
inside the ocean the saltier water means
it's more dense than the water around it
which is how you get a separate pool of
water underneath the water
it's a density gradient with the super
salty water being denser than the
slightly less salty water all around it
therefore all dead jellyfish goo would
need to be in order to prove that it
could bounce along the surface of the
goo lagoon is be less dense than those
super salty pools and we already know
that jellyfish are indeed less dense
than the goo lagoon because it's been
scientifically proven that jellyfish are
95% water making them hardly more dense
than the water that they float around in
that in turn explains how the goo
bubbles are able to float through the
ocean water as well as bounce on top of
the denser brine lake water how about
the way that goo bubbles cluster well
that one's easily explained as well
jellyfish cluster naturally they tend to
travel in groups called blooms and
sometimes rough winds swells and
currents send them to shore all at once
so when they die they tend to die
together exactly the way they lived
explaining why the goo bubbles would
show up together why there would be such
a massive pool of goo in this one
concentrated area another point in favor
of dead rotting jellyfish being the
cause of this whole thing the smell
remember what spongebob and patrick said
earlier pull the smokes pogo stick when
dead jellyfish wash up on shore as they
emit a terrible overpowering smell which
explains why the characters would call
them stench II mean they are dead bodies
after all dead bodies are not
particularly known for their pleasing
smell but why here you might be asking
why are there so many dead jellyfish in
this one concentrated pool but a lot of
it goes back to what goo lagoon is
because it is this super salty brine
lake it would be almost immediately
deadly to any jellyfish that touched it
which explains the dead bodies but there
is another explanation here you see
large blooms of jellyfish are on the
rise which many think is tied to
increasing water temperatures because of
global
warming as a result jellyfish are
starting to pose problems for nuclear
power plants clogging pipes that run
ocean water into cooled reactors and
some places like South Korea have
created jellyfish murder robots to solve
this very problem basically these things
are robotic search-and-destroy sea
blenders for slaughtering hundreds of
jellyfish at a time with fishermen
comparing the texture of the dead
jellyfish goo to margarine which thereby
makes this entire thing rooted in the
type of science the creator of the show
wanted in the first place this episode
isn't a warning about pollution in our
oceans
it's instead an episode warning us about
the dangers of global warming we're
gonna have too many jellyfish and not
enough peanut butter fish probably the
most dad joke I've ever made so there
you have it friends we have ourselves
the color flotation smell the fact that
it's not toxic so Patrick can taste it
reasonably without any negative effects
a reason for it being there the
stickiness all of it is hashed out
through this one explanation I don't
know about you but it looks to me like
Sponge Bob and his pals are in fact
playing with the corpses of their ocean
peers and when those bubbles pop at the
end of the episode everyone is covered
with dead gooey bodies is it gross yeah
morbid absolutely great television you
betcha
but hey that's just a theory
Oh film theory and cut
[Music]
you